TRUMP FIRES BACK AGAINST CRITICS
WHO SEEM TO FEAR HE MIGHT
ACTUALLY MAKE HISTORIC DEAL WITH
NORTH KOREA.
FIRST TRUMP VERSUS THE G.O.P.
AGAIN.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WHEN WILL THEY LEARN?
MORE THAN A YEAR INTO
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FIRST TERM,
YOU WOULD THINK ALL THE
REPUBLICANS WOULD UNDERSTAND
THAT THE ONLY WAY FORWARD IS TO
UNIFY BEHIND HIS AGENDA.
IT'S RESONATING WITH THE PEOPLE.
IT'S BRINGING INTERNATIONAL FOES
TO THE NEGOTIATING TABLE, AND
IT'S HAVING A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
THE ECONOMY.
SOME REPUBLICANS CANNOT HELP BUT
LEND AID AND COMFORT TO THE
PRESIDENT'S POLITICAL ENEMIES.
AS TRUMP SLOWLY BUT SURELY
BEGINS TO REMAKE THE G.O.P. TO
BE MORE RESPONSIVE TO
WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS, BUT
GLOBALIST WING OF THE PARTY IS
STILL IN TOTAL DENIAL.
THE OLD GUARD'S RESISTANCE TO
TRUMP, BEING AMPLIFIED BY A
MEDIA MACHINE THAT'S BEEN TRYING
TO TAKE HIM DOWN SINCE HE FIRST
CAME DOWN THE GOLDEN ESCALATOR.
WATCH HOW UNCOMFORTABLE SOME
REPUBLICANS ARE WHEN PRESSED
ABOUT WHETHER THEY WOULD SUPPORT
THE PRESIDENT AGAIN IN 2020.
>> ANY REPUBLICAN SENATOR THAT
HASN'T BEEN CONFLICTED OVER THIS
PRESIDENCY IS EITHER COMATOSE OR
IS PRETTY USELESS.
>> PREPARED AT THIS POINT TO
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT FOR
REELECTION?
>> I HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
>> IT'S WAY TOO EARLY.
>> NO, IT ISN'T.
NOT TO SAY YOU SUPPORT THE HEAD
OF YOUR PARTY.
>> IT COULD BE A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT WORLD BY 2020.
WE HAVE A 2018 ELECTION FIRST.
>> Laura: RATHER THAN RALLYING
BEHIND THE PRESIDENT AND A SHOW
OF TOTAL UNITY BEFORE THE
MIDTERM, SOME OF THE PARTY END
UP GIVING THE MEDIA WHAT THEY
WANT, A STORY LINE ABOUT A
DIVIDED G.O.P.
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY OF
ABRAHAM LINCOLN'S TIME IS
CENTERED IN THE SOUTH END TRUMP
IS FROM NEW YORK.
ALIEN TERRITORY, THE
CONSERVATIVES.
>> REFLECTS A DIVISION IN THE
PARTY AND HIS OWN
ADMINISTRATION.
>> WOULD YOU RATHER HAVE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY OF PAUL RYAN OR
TRUMP?
>> THERE IS NO CHOICE.
IT'S THE REPUBLICAN PARTY OF
DONALD TRUMP WHICH IS WHY
PAUL RYAN IS LEAVING.
>> Laura: THE TRUTH IS IF YOU
WANT TO SEE REAL DISUNITY, LOOK
AT THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY HAVE NO REAL LEADER.
THEY HAVE MOVED SO FAR LEFT THEY
LEFT AMERICA AND THEY ARE
REDUCED NOW TO EITHER SILLY
ANTICS ARE STAMMERING IN THEIR
ATTEMPTS TO RILE UP THE PACE.
>> IT'S A SCAM.
THE TAX BILL GIVES 83% OF THE
BENEFITS TO THE TOP 1%.
THEY TRIED TO COLLECT A
MIDDLE-CLASS TAX CUTS AND YET
86 MILLION MIDDLE-CLASS FAMILIES
WILL BE PAYING MORE TAXES.
>> Sean: WE WILL BRING IN AN
INTERPRETER NEXT TIME.
THE DEMOCRATS, COME ON.
THEY HAVE SUED THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, WIKILEAKS, THE
RUSSIANS OVER HILLARY CLINTON'S
LOSS IN 2016.
>> DONALD TRUMP'S BEEN SAYING
FOR A YEAR PLUS THIS IS ALL
ABOUT SOUR GRAPES AND IT'S
BECAUSE YOU LOST THE ELECTION.
WHAT SAYS THAT BETTER THAN THE
DNC SUING THEM AND SAYING YOU
LOST US THE SELECTION.
LIKE DAVID AXELROD SAYING IT'S A
WASTE OF TIME AND RESOURCES.
>> Laura: OF COURSE IT IS.
THEY DEMOCRATS CAN'T AGREE ON A
POLITICAL STRATEGY.
TOM PEREZ IN THE DNC FILING
LAWSUITS WHILE OTHER PROMINENT
LIBERALS ARE SHAKING THEIR
HEADS.
FRETTING OVER THERE REELECTION
PROCESS.
SENATOR CLAIRE McCASKILL TOLD
THE ST. LOUIS POST DISPATCH THE
DNC LAWSUIT IS A SILLY
DISTRACTION.
CONGRESSWOMAN JACKIE SPEIER SAID
THIS.
>> I ACTUALLY THINK THIS LAWSUIT
IS ILL-CONCEIVED.
I'M NOT SUPPORTIVE OF IT.
>> Laura: THAT IS WHAT REAL
DISUNITY LOOKS LIKE.
BEYOND THE BLASTER AND THE MEDIA
ATTACKS ON THE PRESIDENT, TRUMPS
REELECTION NUMBERS, CHECK THEM
OUT.
THEY LOOK PRETTY GOOD.
THEY MIRROR THOSE OF
BARACK OBAMA AND BILL CLINTON AT
ABOUT THE SAME POINT IN THEIR
PRESIDENCY.
TODAY'S GALLUP REPORTS THAT
AMONG REGISTERED VOTERS, 37%
BELIEVE TRUMP SHOULD BE
REELECTED.
THAT IS THE SAME PERCENTAGE THAT
THAT BARACK OBAMA SHOULD BE
REELECTED IN 2010.
AT ONE POINT LOWER THAN THOSE WO
SUPPORTIVE BILL CLINTON.
LAST TIME I CHECKED, THEY WERE
BOTH REELECTED, RIGHT?
HERE IS ANOTHER INDICATOR OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE
MIGHT BE IN SOME TROUBLE.
THEY TOOK OUT A $1.7 MILLION
LOAN IN FEBRUARY.
THEY ARE FUND-RAISING, IT IS
PATHETIC.
THERE REPUBLICAN NATIONAL
COMMITTEE TOOK IN $39 MILLION IN
THE FIRST QUARTER ALONE.
DO YOU THINK THAT MIGHT BE
BECAUSE OF THE PRESIDENT?
OF COURSE THE PRESIDENT HAS SOME
WORK TO DO.
HE HAS TO GROW THE POPULIST
MOVEMENT, TAKE HIS MESSAGE TO
UNFRIENDLY TERRITORY, AND
SALADS.
THAT MEANS AND STATES HE DIDN'T
WIN.
GROW THE DAYS.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN PERPETUAL
TEARDOWN RESISTANCE MODE, TRUMP
SHOULD BE PERCEIVED AS A DOER.
HE IS, A LEADER WHO WILL ALWAYS
DEFY AND DRAIN THE SWAMP WILL
NOT BE DEFEATED BY IT.
THAT'S WHAT HE WAS ELECTED IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
ALL THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO DO IS
JUST A FOCUSED ON WHAT MATTERS.
GROWING THE ECONOMY, RETURNING
MORE POWER TO THE PEOPLE,
FIGHTING CORRUPTION ALONG THE
WAY, AND REFUSING TO BE
DISTRACTED OR DETOURED BY THE
CONSTANT AND TEDIOUS
DEMONIZATION GAME OF WASHINGTON
AND THE SEEMINGLY ENDLESS
POINTLESS INVESTIGATIONS.
I KNOW THAT'S EASIER SAID THAN
DONE BUT HE NEEDS TO DO THAT.
LISTEN TO ALL THE NAYSAYERS.
TRUMP'S REELECTION PROSPECTS AND
THOSE OF HIS PARTY ARE ON MORE